you know I told you last time I know you
you radiate you glow
how are you doing I'm doing fantastic
yeah I am doing great I feel very
blessed I'm very honored to be here I
mean what a great event to go to I mean
you know me I'm all about women
empowerment and supporting women I'm
also here actually because I partnered
actually up with Amorous and they are
the sponsors of this event and I have a
huge announcement that's coming in
January and I'm working with them and I
cannot wait to share what I'm doing I
feel like Amorous they're just a great
company to work with because they're all
about clean products sustainability but
yeah I'm just so yes it really really is
and I'm so excited to be here so
I have to tell you you know you I'm
going to say it again you're going on a
different level and I know you're going
through something right now but there's
been a lot of fans who have really just
showed so much love and support what do
you make of that
I am really I have to be honest with you
so overwhelmed by all of the support and
the love that I have received over the
past week or two
um and I'm just so grateful of the
community and just the fans that I have
and the women you know you guys really
do ride for our girls and I really
really appreciate that you know I'm all
about inspiring and encouraging
um and I mean the DMS that I have gotten
from so many women that are going
through the same thing and just saying
how they admire my courage and my
strength it I mean it has just been
I feel so blessed I really really do and
I'm so nice it's so nice to see you I'm
so happy to see you too so I mean you
know I ride for you but I also ride for
Cairo and I ride for cree and I saw they
got that Disney trip oh my God how are
the little ones holding up they are
doing amazing I mean Cairo she is so
wonderful she's awesome she actually
told me a few days ago she was like
Mommy
um do um beetles kiss you and I'm like
oh my gosh where is this coming from and
I'm just going with it I'm like yeah
yeah beetles kiss you and then she was
like Mommy I want to kiss a beetle I'm
like okay but the creative little one it
runs in the Fizz and they're also happy
and that means the world to me my
children so yeah we are in an era of Tia
this is your time to shine what does
this next chapter of life look like for
you
authenticity
I think authenticity it it's very
magical when you are living in your
truth and your honesty I feel like
amazing wonderful things happen and so I
just want to encourage you know all the
women out there to live in their truth
and to live in their authenticity and we
got you you know what I mean we're all
in this together it's about a community
and supporting each other and
encouraging each other and inspiring
each other and I mean there's so many
great things that are happening in my
life and I just feel so grateful
um and blessed this time baby I really
appreciate that love you you're so sweet
[Music]